Coport just dropped and it might be the
biggest contender to competing with open
claw we've ever seen. Now Alibaba, one
of the biggest tech companies on the
planet, just released their own free
agent. You can see the announcement
right here. So this is a tweet from AI
search and you can see that Tongi Lab
actually announced that Copore was
available right here. And basically
this is running via a free AI agent. It
does almost everything open claw does.
It can run on your computer. It
remembers everything. and it works on
its own 24/7. Now, here's where it gets
wild because copore apparently can
actually do things OpenClaw cannot do
right now. Things that once you see
them, you'll wonder how you ever used
agents without them. So, today we're
going to check it out and just see how
it runs. If you want to take a look at
it, it's open source. You can see on
GitHub right here. This is Copore and
this is running from Alibaba, right?
This is your personal assistant. Easy to
install. You can deploy it. It was
fairly easy to set up. What I would say
is when you're using this, use something
like clawed code to help you get it set
up because it can be a little bit of
work unless you're super technical. And
you can see an example right here. Now,
this is a preview in Chinese, but you
can run it in English as you can see.
And then to run it, it's just like a
oneline install like this. You can also
run it using Docker, which is what I did
today. And then once you've done that,
you can actually set it up with like
local models or all sorts of models that
you want to use. So here's an example of
how it runs. If you go over to the
coport console over here, this is
coport. And you can see for example, we
actually created this landing page. So
inside the chat, one of the first things
I would say is like it did even when I
selected English, it started speaking to
me in Chinese. So you can see an example
of it speaking to me in Chinese here.
Um, and then what we actually did was we
just said like just reply in English and
then it switched back to English. And
from there I actually wanted to run a
test to create a website. Right now the
website itself is pretty awesome. Like
look at this website that it's created
and it just built this using the prompt
that I'll give you. So it was a oneshot
prompt. It just went off and created the
whole page which is pretty crazy. Like
all the FAQs um were created. The colors
are pretty nice, very colorful, very
interesting. Actually looks better than
the original in many ways. And if we go
back to Cop, I'll show you how we did
this. So literally you can use it inside
the chat here. You can say for example
like build a beautiful um fun landing
page that's easy to use and then
actually just pasted in the information
from the AR profitable boardroom into
the chat. Now from there he said sure
I'll build you this let me create
something that hits different blah blah
blah and it went off created it. You can
see that it's sort of coding out right
there and it's like done I've created
this here's the link to it. So it's
actually coded locally and here's why
it's good etc. Here's the key sections
that it's added and it's like if you
want any tweaks or anything like that
just let me know. Now the one thing that
I'll say here is like the browser use
was not working so well. So what I'd
recommend is that if you want it to use
browser use properly just go back into
claw code and get it configured properly
but it was pretty easy to set up. And
the interesting thing is on the left
hand side here you can see that you can
select like channel sessions chron jobs
and heartbeat just like open claw right
it really does it must be like a open-
source version that was built around
openclaw in the first place. Now if we
go to the settings over here you can see
that you can switch between different
settings and I'm actually running this
with O Lama right so this is running we
can run it locally with OMA you can
choose which for example um which model
you want to use inside the list so you
can run this completely for free and
it's quite easy to set up the API right
so for example we could run this with
quen 3.5 we could run this with for
example GLM 4.7 and these are both local
free models so that number one copore is
free to set up you can just run it from
gith GitHub and then O Lama is free to
to set up and run locally as well,
right? And then you've got an autonomous
AI agent running locally on your laptop
just like OpenClaw and it's just running
for free 24/7. Pretty crazy. Now, if we
go over to the workspace here, you can
quickly edit your files and that sort of
thing. I want to see as well actually,
can we can we change it to um to dark
mode? Right. So, right now it's pretty
bright. That's what I would prefer it if
it was in dark mode. It doesn't seem to
be, but I wonder if you can switch it in
some way. I'm sure you could if I played
around with it a bit more. And then you
can run it with all your main sort
models, right? The main one I would
probably focus on if I was you, um, if
you're testing this out, it's just using
the free OAM as you can see over here.
Any bugs or anything like that, just go
over to Claude Code and say, can you
help me fix this? Or, this isn't
working, blah, blah, blah. That's what I
did when I had a couple of problems with
it set up, but literally got it set
within about, I would say, 10 to 15
minutes and it was pretty simple. Now,
you can add MCP clients over here,
right? which means you can link this to
tools um just by pasting in the MCP
details over here with your API keys and
that means that basically you can make
this even more powerful by linking it to
tools externally and then your
autonomous AI agent with copore can go
off and start doing stuff and the other
thing I would say here is like it
doesn't break on me as much as something
like openclaw and I'll give you an
example like a real cool example from
today so for example with openclaw here
we've already updated to the latest
version but it's still got a
notification to update at the top, which
doesn't make sense. We've already
updated, right? We're already on the
latest version. So, just something to be
aware of there. Now, the other thing
that I like as well is that you see on
this section here, you can add multiple
chats, right? Which means that you can
have parallel agents working on multiple
different tasks at the same time. So,
for example, we could say, okay, code a
Pomoduro timer over here, right? Then we
could go over to this chat and we could
say, okay, code a fun
snake game, right? something like that,
right? And then we can have multiple
chats running with the AI agent and just
they're all working in parallel
together, right? That's a pretty simple
and easy way to to just have multiple
chats working so that you can have these
agents um working in parallel and you
can have different stuff running at the
same time. Now, let's have a look inside
the chat here. See what we got. I'm
going to I'm going to come back to these
questions actually in a second. So, um
we focus on on this particular update.
Now, you can see we have multiple
sessions running here. So, you can
switch between sessions. You can set up
uh schedule tasks just like you would
with openclaw. You've got the heartbeat
file which basically is like this will
send you updates, right? So every few
hours you can get updates. Um and you
can change the interval. So you can say
okay update me every hour or something
like that. And then you've got sessions
and channels, right? So with with the
channels, you can actually link this to
Discord. I couldn't see an option for
Telegram, but you can link it to
Discord, Q, um a couple other Chinese
messaging apps, but probably the main
one that most people watching this would
use is Discord. But you can use the UI,
right? And that's basically how it
works. So
you just put in the chat here what you
want to do. Because it's using O Lama,
it's obviously going to be a little bit
slower, but you can see it does actually
work and it does it does work directly
here. So that's basically how to use it.
It's pretty simple to set up. Would I
say it's as good as something like
OpenClaw? Probably not. it was a little
bit buggy when it was using browser
control whereas browser control seems to
work fine if you're using something like
openclaw but I think either way it's
just interesting to test these
alternatives out and the overall trend
here is like things are becoming more
autonomous more agents are being
released Alibaba is obviously taking
this seriously because you can see um
how it's working and then you can also
see here that we've created this
pomodora timer right um using the local
API from Alama so it didn't cost us
anything to to set that up as well which
is pretty cool now let's just have a
little preview of it so yeah that's how
the page looks Looks like um pretty
simple and easy to set up. And then
we've got the timer ready to go here.
Right. So this is the Pomodoro timer. We
just asked Copore to create which you
can see right here. It's working
perfectly. Pretty interesting design and
pretty cool. It's got an alarm as well
at the top and then you can reset the
timer as well. And then you actually get
like um a streak at the bottom so you
can track how many sessions you've done.
So it's all working fine. It seems to
create stuff pretty cool. The one of the
biggest differences I think is like you
get the chat options so you can come
back to your history and that sort of
thing. And then also just seems a lot
easier to configure because you can
switch between APIs in the settings. So
that just makes it a lot easier as you
can see.
Now just to recap here, um we do have
like a 30-day system for building AI
agents with Copore inside the video
notes from today inside the AR profit
boardroom. Um and you might be
wondering, okay, what is copore? Why
does it actually matter? So it's an open
source AI agent built by Alibaba's Tongi
Lab team, right? It was fully open
sourced on February the 28th and it's
got a long-term memory that actually
works. It remembers your preferences. No
more starting from scratch. Local vector
to search. It runs locally first. So it
runs natively with Llama as you see
today, which means you can run it for
free and it's it's all like sort of
running locally for you. You can connect
it to multiple different message
channels. And the interesting thing here
is you can actually build your own
channel plugins, right, with a
standardized protocol, which is pretty
cool. So
the biggest difference I think between
these is like if you look at something
like Copore, it's really designed and I
think this is this sort of coincides
with Quen 3.5 coming out which is local,
free, and really powerful from Alibaba.
I think they've designed this agent to
work alongside Quen 3.5. And then you
can see here there's a 30-day road map
if you want to test this out. We've got
day-to-day um prompts for really
mastering this if you want to check out
and how to use it and that sort of
thing. And then we've got 100 prompts as
you can see down here uh to test this
out. So just to recap, is Alibaba's open
source AI agent. It was released end of
February. Local first, memory first,
model modular architecture. Zero cost
because you can run it with alarm. It
connects to Discord, iMessage, and a
bunch of other messaging apps. In terms
of copore versus openclaw, so both are
powerful. Copore is more local, right?
Whereas openclaw is more cloud-based
when you're using APIs unless you're
running it locally as well with alarm.
And it's just like different
philosophies and different UI as well, I
would say.
So, thanks so much for watching. If you
want to get all the video notes from
today, you can get that inside the
arriting. We actually have a full
six-hour course on openclaw if you want
to check that out and another three-hour
course on open claw right here. And we
had new daily updates inside the
profitable boardroom. As you can see,
this is my AI automation community, the
AI profitable link in the comments
description or go to a profitable.com.
And this basically shows you how to save
time, scale, and grow with AI. Now,
inside the community, we have 2,500
members. So, you can ask questions, get
help, get support whenever you need it.
There's always people online to help.
What you can also do, for example, is
you can go inside the calendar and get
video calls, live automation, AI
automation coaching. So, you can ask
questions, meet the community, ask any
questions you have. If you ever get
stuck, they're great to go on. Inside
the map, you can actually zoom into your
local area and then meet people in your
local area and that sort of thing. And
then, additionally, inside the
classroom, you'll get all my best
trainings. Now, at this point, you might
be saying, "Okay, are people actually
getting results with this?" So, we have
133 pages of of testimonials at this
point. is basically an endless scroll.
And what's cool about this is, as you
can see right here, there's lots of
people winning with this stuff, right?
So, it's it's it's something where you
can go learn AI, get results. I mean,
for example, Russell was selling AI
avatar videos. Eric landed a new client.
Dan got his first customer in two weeks.
Like, and there's 133 pages of people
getting results like that. So, it's a
pretty awesome community and definitely
worth checking